Do you enjoy awkward
conversations
with members of an entrenched
political dynasty,
but you're also very hungry?
Well, great news.
Now you can enter
to win a dinner
with distinguished lady Magneto
Hillary Clinton.
-(laughter) -It'll just be like
eating a meal with your mom
if 54% of America
hated your mom.
-(laughter)
-All you got to do...
-Well...
-Stop.
(applause and cheering)
(as Clinton):
"What do I want?
What's your favorite thing?"
-Uh...
-(laughter)
All you need to do is give her
your e-mail address,
so, if you don't want
a free meal,
you'll still get served
some spam.
Comedians, what will they serve
at dinner with Hillary Clinton?
Bonnie.
-Uh, pants soup.
-HARDWICK: Yes. Perfect.
-(laughter)
-Jim Florentine.
-Bull (bleep) on a stick.
-(laughter)
HARDWICK:
All right. All right, points.